let's start the
introduction all right um welcome to the
ddps seminar everyone before we
introduce our speaker today let's go
over some rules and Logistics first of
all please mute yourself during the talk
but if you have questions you can unmute
and ask questions or use chat room to
post your questions so that we can
address them in Q&A session at the end
uh second today's ddps seminar is open
to external audience uh therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out uh finally The Talk
today will be recorded and uploaded in
our YouTube channel okay uh let me now
briefly introduce our speaker today it
is an honor to host Dr Fabio Gian Paulo
who is a research fellow in computer
science and artificial intelligence and
they member of the model research group
at the University of Naple fed Rico uh
to where he received uh his PhD in the
mathematics and
applications member of the editorial
board uh of the journal neural Computing
and applications and he published by um
published by Springer and he has
co-authored uh articles in international
journals and Conference papers on both
applicative and methodological Research
In The Deep learning field his research
interests include machine learning and
deep learning with a particular focus on
exploring the Dynamics of learning uh
this Explorations encompasses a wide
range of topics including the
development of innovative neural network
architectures the investigation on new
learning algorithms efficiency and the
application of these methodologies to
solve complex real world problems today
uh Dr uh Gian Paul will'll talk about
learning paradigms for neural networks
and the locally back propagated word for
algorithms um please enjoy and expect a
wonderful talk from him uh now let me
ask a questions uh to our speaker just
to make this stage somewhat
informal um is it okay ask yeah of
course all right awesome um so we we
usually do that okay um obviously you're
passionate about the Deep learning or NE
Network um would you share with us the
moment when you realize that you need
you want to uh dive into this
community yeah this is a good question
you know I was a uh one of those kids
that was always in front of his computer
you know trying to to to code and some
something like that so uh when I found
out that in the department
I was there was a research group dealing
with this kind of topics and in
particular on how machine can learn no I
was very fascinated by by by this so uh
I asked them to to work with them I
started to work with them and so that's
how that's winded up where I am now
awesome awesome well these days you you
probably are more fashionate best ated
by what they can
do all right the stage is yours okay I
will share my presentation
so full screen can you see the
presentation by now yeah yeah but it's
not full screen okay can make it is it
now yeah yeah it is okay thank you so I
will start of course of good morning
everyone first of all I would like to
thank again youngu and the organizers
for giving me the opportunity to hold
this
seminar uh as you said that Fab jow
resar fellow at the University of Naples
federo SEO and a member of the model
research
group this is a brief outline on what we
are going to discuss today we will start
by introducing briefly some basic
concepts on neural networks the the way
a neural network is is tailored to a
specific task and some fundamental
concepts around the learning process
then we will move on to some
manipulation some experiments about the
manipulation of the learning Dynamics
and we will uh end the presentation by
discussing some applications of the main
ideas we developed uh in the field of
Federated
learning I think the audience is
familiar with the concepts shown here so
I will just introduce them very very
briefly we know that the neuron is the
foundational computational unit which
all the neural networks are built and we
also know that it can be seen as a toep
process first the input under go a weed
sum which is also added another term
bias and then the result of this sum is
processed through a usually no linear
transformation here denoted as Lambda
which is the activation function so uh a
deep Network can be seen as a stack of
stata the layers which the neurons are
ra and from a general perspective it can
be imagined
as as composed by three main segments no
the input layer which inest data the the
layers that work together to extract
complex patterns from data and to
provide the functional representation
for these
patterns and then the output data that
provides the the output that aligns with
the task we are dealing with it should
be underlined that some theoretical
results exist about this this kind of
structures as in particular about the
approximation power of these kind of
structures as in particular demonstrated
by the universal approximation theorems
usually these results concern the
approximation capabilities of if F the
forward the neural network on Space of
the continuous functions and the
approximation is with respect to the
compact convergence topology however
despite the importance results like this
one have from a
mathematical perspective in the
formulation of a neural network they
come with a major concern somehow they
do not provide a construction rule for
the weight that for the synapsis for the
connections of of these
networks so in this scenario uh we may
say that the uh deep learning problem
the learning problem can be seen as the
problem of learning the connection
weights of a large computational graph
but in order to to address this task we
must introduce another basic yet
fundamental Concept in the learning
framework which is the loss function
this function basically measures the
discrepancy between the models
predictions and the target values and
can be formalized as reported here it's
worth noticing that we may say that the
loss function somehow encapsulates the
the objective of the task by measuring
the models deviations from this
objective and in this slide I reported
the general formulation for a l function
with also some desired properties which
are actually not always fulfilled and
with the concept of loss function we can
reframe the the learning problem as an
optimization problem no which deals with
the loss function in this in this
framework our task is to find a set of
Weights that minimizes the loss function
so considering a Network made up of n
units uh we should find a learning rule
somehow know a a way to adjust weights
in such a way this condition uh is uh is
fulfilled the condition reported the
partial derivative of the loss function
with respect to the variations the
variation of all the of all the weights
in any critical point it is peculiar to
notice that uh uh even if the research
uh on this topic has been huge somehow
only few algorithms have been proposed
to to do that and with the reference to
the table we may also notice that all
the familiar learning rules we are used
to somehow can be seen as special cases
or variations of the two main learning
rules which are the Aban one and the
back propagation one which are different
in their
Essence however uh in this framework
another important question arises and
that is to say what characteristics
should learning rules have to guarantee
an efficient learning
process following what we said we should
requir that learning rules depend on
variables that are locally available as
shown here for example on variables that
could be uh the preoptic activity the
postoptic activity and the weight
itself then uh we must notice here that
the targets will be considered local
only for the output l of the network and
if we stop here we obtain what we call
the Deep local learning which of course
basically by applying these two learning
uh rules layer by layer from the input
one to the output one however it could
be can be demonstrated that in this
framework for a network it is impossible
to learn optimally a complex function
and in order to to address this we must
require that some sort of information is
propagated from the from the targets to
the internal weights of the architecture
and this is what happens in what we call
local deep learning in which the generic
learning rule is modified by adding the
dependence of some sort of information
that transvers the network and arrives
to the to the Deep weight moreover we
can also require that this information
comes in a simplified version some
somehow for example depending only on
the postoptic activities and in this
case we can obtain a formulation for the
learning rule as reported in equation
three which can be proven to be
equivalent equivalent to a local
supervised rule in which the targets is
directly delivered to the to the to the
weight and why is this important because
back propagation for example works just
like that so let's for a moment focus on
the back propagation
I think that also this this process is
well known here but I will discuss it
very very very beautifully uh we know
that the back propagation is the the
standard way a neural network is trained
basically and it can it can be imagined
as a two-step process to two pass
process somehow the for in the forward
pass as the information crosses the
layers it is transformed by all the
weights and activation functions of each
computational unit
and in this way uh the model is able to
produce a prediction that can be
compared with the expected Target value
so we can measure a distance between
these two quantities in the backward
pass the information about this error is
propagated backwards through the network
by applying the chle of calculus to the
composite function of the loss and all
the operation performed the operations
performed by the layers of the network
and this is reported in this three
equation basically in which we can see
how the error computed on the last layer
of the network is transmitted to the
generic internal weight by the
recurrence pattern which is obtained by
applying the the chain rule to the
generic fit forward formulation and in
the whole training process these two
steps are iteratively performed until we
we reach minimum for the loss function
or usually until we met a stopping
criteria we can also reconnect
the the back propagation with the
concept of local deep local deep
learning by considering a learning rule
in a multiplicative form in which
appears the Target now recalling what is
the learning rule for the back
propagation which is basically uh the
equation six here through some
straightforward manipulations we can
obtain a formulation for this uh Target
T in terms of the back propagated error
and notice that here we use the the
simplified form of information I ofi uh
since back propagation shows that it is
possible actually to deliver uh the same
information to all the synapses
connected to uh impinging to the same
neuron in this context we can also write
down a a general formulation for for
this learning rule with back propagation
being a special case in which can we can
notice that the information depends on
the targets on the output and all on all
the upper layers of the network and all
the upper
derivatives by the way there is a reason
why the back propagation is so efficient
and then so widely used if we perform a
TA expansion of the error function
around the generic weight and also
considering Mo fluctuation Delta w we
can somehow uh estimate uh the
effectiveness of the information
transmitted to the Deep weights to first
to approximation we can see that the
information that is sent back to the
Deep weights can be interpreted in terms
of how how well it approximates the
gradient G and since the most
information of the gradient is contained
in its direction the estimation of what
here we called o returns a measure more
or less of how good is the corresponding
the corresponding optimization
optimisation
step together with gradient information
we can also estimate some other
quantities which basically deal with the
efficiency of the the transmission of
this information a very interesting
discussion about this topic is in a work
of Balan sadosi from which also this
figure is taken and they demonstrate
basically that in this framework back
propagation is optimal since it achieves
both the max maximal possible rate of
information and maximum possible
possible
Improvement now despite the optimality
of back propagation and also its very
efficient uh implementations from a
computational point of view uh the
research in looking for alternatives to
to this learning algorithm have has
found more and more space in the
community and one of the main concern uh
about B proration is its biological
plausibility
there is no convincing evidence that
biological networks explicitly propagate
gradate error
information uh or store neural
activities for the subsequent use in a
backward pass or again the the the
requirement for such a strict symmetry
of the weights across the learning seems
particularly implausible so these
considerations with also others briefly
reported here have pushed the research
in this on this this topic
somehow but uh also from a practical
point of view not only from a
theoretical philosophical somehow if you
want point of view back propagation
shows some drawbacks that limit its
application and in particular the need
for computing the gradient of the loss
with respect the the whole composition
of the layers functions may be difficult
or even not possible in some in some
cases the most straightforward example
reported here is uh the presence of a
black box inside the model unless we
unless the inside the architecture
unless we provide a differentiable model
for this component derivatives cannot be
computed and so we cannot apply back
propagation in this case of course we
may rely on different strategies for
example reinforcement learning or
evolutionary algorithm but often these
Alternatives increase computational
demand and are less efficient at
scale one might wonder when this
limitation where when we are forced to
to face with this limitation in real
cases here I've reported just few
examples for example the integration of
AI systems with Legacy systems uh that
not always but often lack the interfaces
for gradient based learning or realtime
decision systems in which are involved
the threshold based class ifers or rule
based systems or again in in techniques
involving pruning spcification for
example as concern the network
architecture search here uh are involved
the nondifferentiable operations usually
like thresholding or masking or probably
in the most interesting context which is
the integration between AI systems and
and humans in which here we must
consider as inputs preferences or
qualitative feedbacks which are
inherently nondifferentiable and which
may make radian computation a
problem following uh uh some of these
considerations in particular the
theoretical
ones driven by the implausibility of the
back propagation December 2022 Professor
Jeoffrey Inon proposed an alternative
learning learning procedure called the
forward forward algorithm which replaces
basically the forward pass and backward
pass of the back propagation with two
forward passes one on positive data and
the other one on negative data and with
positive and negative data we're
basically referring to uh actual data
real data and wrong data in this
framework each layer has its own
objective function whose name could be
simply described as having a high
goodness for positive samples and a low
goodness for negative one and in
particular the objective of of the task
of the learning process is to achieve a
goodness value which is significantly
above a certain threshold in this case
Theta for positive samples for real data
and significantly below the threshold
for negative data so for example in a
classification example in a
classification context the goal is to
accurately classify an input Vector as
positive or negative with the
probability for an input Vector being
classified as positive given by applying
the logistic function to the goodness
value minus the threshold and if we
moreover can connect the goodness
function with the neural activities for
example through the norm as reported
here we can write down the layer wise
loss function uh as reported in as shown
in equations 16 17 and 18 uh it's uh
interesting to notice that in this
scenario the the weight update rule uh
becomes in the form reported in the blue
box in which we can notice that the
information I depends only loses its
dependence on the upper derivatives and
this somehow localizes the learning on
on the
layer but how does this learning process
behave in the context of a supervised
learning task in this slide I reported a
the behavior of the learning somehow in
the case of a classification task
involving the data set time list it's
worth underlining that mnist is very
well known and the behavior of simple
networks trained through back
propagation on these data sets are or
data set like like M are well studied in
literature so this makes uh m is very
convenient for testing out new learning
strategies to to see if they actually
work however in this context for in the
for the for forward algorithm the the
classification is uh is done by
accumulating the goodness of WBA the
first layer for each label and then
taking the label with the highest
accumulated goodness now in general we
know that deep networks consist of
multiple layers and we can say that each
layer uh processes its input and returns
to the subsequent layer with it has
constructed and in a network trained by
back propagation this allows for an
increasingly complex representation of
data since the learning happens in a
hierarchical
manner uh for example uh in this in this
case the amist case we may see that
first layers of the architecture will
extract simpler features for example
edges and later layers of the same
architecture will construct more complex
features for example uh shapes but uh in
this hierarchical representation of data
uh basically allows the network to build
a robust representation for for the data
and uh to provide accurate predictions
in the case of the pure forward forward
algorithm instead it could be said that
each layer returns a measures of
consistency between the sample and the
Target and this can be seen from the
figure I reported here in which is shown
the the norm of the neural activities
for all the layers uh with respect to
the association between the sample seven
and all the possible targets from 0 to 9
and we can see that in this case the the
learning somehow flows through the
network since each layer receives no
feedback on what's happening in the
later parts of the of the structure the
Neal structure and this obviously
impacts the overall convergence process
the figure on the on the left here
report the error provided by the layers
one two three and the stock of the
cumulative error provided by the stock
uh which goes from one to three as
concern the layers in this case we can
see that for example layers two and
three do not positively contribute to
the prediction since their marginal
contribution is negative basically the
first layers uh provides a lower eror
with respect the others and the same
thing can be seen also in the two
figures on the right in which are
reported the accuracy of uh stack of
layers of increasing Dimension from 1 to
five from 1 to 10 and from 1 to 15 and
we can see that for the data sets mnist
and fashion mnist in this case and we
can see that these three lines at some
point
separate uh indicating that somehow each
layer is less capable of the preceding
layer to understand how to work with the
input is receiving and this uh leads to
two main consideration the first is that
a neural network trained with the pure
for forward algorithm struggles in
learning Collective
representations and from this follows
the fact that the for forward algorithm
better performs with small networks
shallow networks networks made by few
layers however these new learning
strategies has also some peculiarities
we are interested in for example since
the learning is somehow local uh there
is no need for the back ation and its
update process and this is interesting
since it allow us for example to insert
in an Neal architecture a non
differentiable a blackbox and non
differentiable component without
impacting the whole training procedure
moreover we know that uh uh each layer
directly contribute to the prediction
process and this is also interesting if
we think for example uh about the the
the importance of Ensemble methodologies
in the field of machine learning so with
the idea of enhancing the efficacy of
the forward algorithm we developed a
methodology whose basic idea is to split
a neural network in blocks then applying
the back propagation inside each uh
block but training each one of the
blocks according to a forward forward
strategy a small remark here involves
the third consideration since no error
information is propagated backwards
words we we can say that the first layer
of the network somehow will be optimized
sooner with respect to the other layers
of the same architecture but we will
discuss this point in few slides u in
order to make our approach even more
efficient basically
sorry basically the the split strategy
has been formalized as reported in this
slide we can say that the generic neural
network can be partitioning in capital K
non overlapping sub
networks uh and that the follow the the
the weight update process follows back
propagation approach inside each sub
networks where the error that is
propagated backwards depends on the
goodness function evaluated on the last
layer of the of the of the block of the
sub Network it's worth noticing that in
this context except for for the first
one of the blocks whose input is simply
the data we have for each one of the
blocks the input will be the output of
the proceding block so we are preserving
the general fed forward
architecture now in neural networks
trained with back propagation we know
the that all the layers interact
collaborate to minimize the loss
function so we may say that each
internal layer is loss function which is
computed on the last layer with the
results of the last layer so we may say
that uh in a back propagation process
each internal layer of the architecture
is optimized in the sense
uh in the sense of giving a good
embedding uh to the to the subsequent
layers but this fact in our approach
means that uh uh internal layers of the
blocks will not contribute to the to the
prediction process and this is basically
what we are seeing here from this figure
in which you can we can observe that uh
while for layers 2 47 and
19 uh while these layers fulfill the
condition the goodness condition somehow
internal layers of the of the network uh
do not know how to how to fulfill the
the the the prediction uh task no
and uh uh given that since we wanted to
push on one side the layer interaction
but on the other side we wanted to
preserve the layer West prediction
contribution we developed a randomized
partitioning strategy with the basically
consists in fixing the number of the
block of the blocks in which the network
is split but varing at the fix randomly
varying at the fixed number of of ofo
their sides the extrem and this
guarantees that more or less during the
training all the layers will undergo the
the optimization Criterion dictated by
the the goodness function so preserving
the characteristic we are interesting in
and here we can observe how the random
um the random reorganization of the of
the blocks impacts the learning pattern
somehow recovering the the L wse
prediction contribution it can be from
the last image here on the on the on the
right of course in this scenario two
main questions arise uh if the
interaction between layers is actually
improved and if uh we obtain a better
convergence pattern of the entire
network and this second
questions arises from the consideration
that now the layers are optimized also
in the sense of giving a good embedding
to the subsequent lers so we expect a
more coherent learning pattern across
the Hood
Network and in particular in this slide
we can observe that actually the the
random organization Works somehow as
expected we can see that the three lines
that uh that I discussed before now for
example in the case of am data set
collapse but also in the case of fashion
amist data set even if they still
separate at some point the pattern of
convergence is much more coherent is
smoother somehow and another thing that
we can notice is that the overall
accuracy is here in terms of error is uh
is
improved of course uh this proposed
strategy introduces two other hyper
parameters that is to say the number of
the blocks in which the network is split
and the um the EPO for the random to to
wait until the random
reorganization fixing this last
parameter to five we can see on the left
that actually reducing the number of the
blocks uh stabilizes the convergence
while increasing the number of the
blocks returns a convergence pattern
this time in terms of accuracy much more
similar to the pure forward forward
which is the the blue line and this is
explainable by the fact that uh if the
network is fragmented information about
the layer interaction struggle in
transversing the the whole network so we
have a Behavior Uh like in in the
forward forward algorithm 10 blocks
means two layers per block basically on
the other side we can see that
increasing the frequency for the random
reorganization stabilizes and accelerate
the convergence in this case while
decreasing this frequency uh produces a
a slower convergence
behavior and this is
explainable uh by the fact that if we
fix a block for a considerable number of
epochs back propagation will saturate
somehow the optimization of the last of
the of the last layer of the Block in
terms of goodness function while not
optimizing the internal layers of the
Block in in this sense so uh patterns
just like for example this staircase
appear which is in the case of the we
are dealing with 25 EV EPO to wait until
organization and I would say this
staircase pattern pattern appear by the
way in uh in both the cases uh we can
observe that the overall convergence
overall accuracy is increment
mented and this somehow shows that uh
the presence of black propagated blocks
somehow pushes the the layer interaction
and uh leads to a more coherent behavior
during the
training this is basically a a a trick a
kind of a trick we developed exploiting
the third characteristic I discussed
before we wanted to uh uh enhance the
efficient the efficiency of the learning
process and so we exploited the
sequential refinement of the learning
procedure the fact that first layers of
an architecture will be optimized sooner
with respect to the later layers of the
same architecture from the forward
forward and we did this uh by assigning
to each layer a probability to be
trained drawn from a ke Square
distribution and so the generic Block in
this uh framework will undergo the
optimization process according to a
probability given by the probabilities
of its constitutive blocks its
constitutive layers sorry uh in this uh
in this scenario we also observed the
loss function of the first of the TR
blocks and if it reaches a steady state
if it reaches a plateau the parameter F
of the square distribution is
incremented in such a way we
redistribute the probabilities in favor
of the later layers of the of the
architecture of of course all this after
an initial Global training of the
network and we found out that uh while
this trick somehow does not impact very
much the convergence it impacts the
computational times we wanted to produce
a more efficient learning procedure with
respect to the forward forwards so we
evaluated the computational times per on
the left on the right we can see what
happens without the random training and
we can see here that the frequency of
the random reorganization does not
impact the computational times while the
number of the blocks does and but this
is quite obvious since we know that the
back propagation is very efficient also
from a computational point of view so uh
the more the layers in a in a block the
less the computational time somehow on
the right we can see that both the in
both the situations uh the random
training further
reduces uh this
quantity almost helping the
computational time per ook with respect
to the P for forward so we developed
basically a strategy that uh makes this
learning process even more efficient and
so somehow widely usable in a real
context not only in experimental
ones and uh given the good results of
the locally back propagated forward
forward we tried also to develop some
applications uh based on its fundamental
ideas in particular in the field of
Federated learning what is federating
learning briefly we know that
conventional ai ai models are typically
trained on single data set located on a
single machine and this requires the
data to be aggregated but it is not
always feasible possible to centralize
data and reasons can vary from legal to
confidential so the Federated learning
approach is the Federated learning is an
approach is a paradigm where multiple
entities called clients collaborate in
solving machine learning problem under
the orchestration of a central server
and all these while keeping their data
set localized so this Paradigm shifts
the traditional centralized model
training to a more distributed approach
which preserves data privacy and allows
to adere uh to legal and
confidentiality constraints and of
course this decentralized approaches are
are interesting in a plethora of of
fields but in particular where the
Privacy is a is a strict uh constraint
for example in fields like healthcare or
military def military research but it
also pushes the boundaries somehow of
the distributed computation for machine
and deep
learning since it allows the model
training to be conducted on a on a large
scale by Distributing the computational
load across multiple nodes and this is
particularly interesting in situations
where EXT extensive simulations are
required for example climate modeling or
large scale industrial process but how
does the the the training of the local
and the global model Ur in the typical
Federated learning Federated learning
setting in general the server
initializes the weights for a glal model
in a random way delivers these weights
to the clients that perform some local
training on their data sets and then
send back the information about weights
updates uh to the server that Aggregates
this information
and updates uh the global model and this
can be done that the exchange of
information about the way update can be
done by uh transmitting the gradients or
transmitting the weights uh in each
training Epoch for the local clients as
for example in fed SGD or waiting uh for
some learning on the on the clients and
then sending back these weights as infed
AVG and and uh it's important to notice
that this second approach is usually
preferred since it reduces the
communication frequency and so the load
for the communication
channel of course this Paradigm comes
with its own set of challenges and among
them probably one of the most important
one concerned the um the non idess of
data which basically refers to different
data distributions across the clients
this can manifest in uh several forms
that I briefly reported here but
probably the most uh the most common one
is the label distributions CU in which
uh there is a very different
distributions very there are very
different distributions of the label
across the the various clients and
addressing this uh this set of
challenges these these issues is
important since they it can these issues
May lead to inconsistent model updates
and theg graded Global performances of
the model in particular a wellknown
issue related to the nonas is the model
Divergence which consists basically in
local model local models becoming very
different from each others and this uh
causes a problem when the server
Aggregates uh these models in order to
obtain the global the global model
moreover uh over multi
communication rounds this discrepancies
May accumulate so causing the global
model to diverge and of course
negatively impacting the performances of
the whole training
process uh another challenge important
challenge in this field is uh what we
call device
heterogenity which refers to different
Hardware capabilities uh among the
clients we know that in typical
Federated learning paradigms paradigma
uh uniform model structures are required
across client but this may limit the
full utilization of the computational
power we can think for example a a
client that is less capable it is less
powerful than the others which may
become a struggler slowing down so the
entire uh training procedure moreover
the visen may also introduce uncertainty
and instability
uh since for example a device with a
limited storage capability uh May
struggle in handling large model updates
so causing it to causing it to drop out
of the training procedure or send uh
incomplete
updates of course several Solutions have
been proposed to face these two
challenges and in particular on one side
as concern onas usually techniques
involve the introduction of some
regularization terms which forces the
weights to not diverge or in Waiting
terms um related to data
distributions as concerned
devisen uh some strategies rely on
client selection but this may introduce
biases if not all the clients equally
participate to the training process or
on split learning which rise private
concerns due to uh Comm the
communication of the of the gradients of
gradients information so in this
scenario and in particular in order to
address the challenge of the dataor Gen
we exploited the idea of splitting a
neural networking blocks from locally
propagated for forward in the context of
Federated learning this strategies this
strategy allows us to train different
pieces of uh of a global model on
different
clients uh According to some uh some
rule which for example can depend on the
computational capabilities of the client
and this is what is briefly described in
this slide we basically imagine that
each client Rees receives a partial
replica of the global model
consisting in a subset of the blocks in
which the global model is split perform
the training on this block Bo and then
send the weights to the to the server
that Aggregates these weights in order
to to obtain the global model and this
here is reported for this operation here
is described as for example a an average
a simple average but uh this is not a
strict constraint in sense that here we
can use all the aggregation techniques
from the Federated learning field and
this makes this uh this technique this
approach widely usable
in this context of course we must recall
two important facts that is to say that
the output of the generic block also
serves as input for the for the
subsequent block we are in a Fed forward
context and that the optimization of the
generic block is somehow aware of what's
happening before in the network but not
in the subsequent parts of the same
network and this implies that the
partial replicas of the of the global
model delivered to the clients must
start from its first block and this
means that according of course to the
settings of the of the Federated
learning uh procedure but uh there's the
possibility that the last blocks of the
global model uh could remain untrained
so in order to overcome this issue we
exploited the uh sequential refinement
of the learning by observing the
difference for each generic
communication round the difference
between the weights of the trained local
model the weights of a block of course
uh of the train uh of a trained local
model and the weights of the global
model refering to that block uh at the
previous communication round which is
basically the quantity have reported in
this uh in this
slide and if uh this quantity approaches
to zero for the majority of the clients
this block is Frozen is excluded from
the training and the structures of the
partial replicas of the global models
delivered to the clients are modified
accordingly as reported in this box
basically and this is important uh if we
consider that in this way uh all the
blocks of the global model will be
trained by all the clients involved in
this procedure and uh uh this is of
primary importance since uh we talked
before about the non of data so
considering that each client has its own
data set which may be different from the
the other data sets of the other
clients and this is basically a
graphical representation of what I just
said uh we can see that in the first
communication round the the server
delivers to the model to the clients
sorry uh the partial replicas of the
model at at some point in the training
if the first block uh reaches a Ste
state from a training point of view it
is frozen it is blocked and the
structure of the of the partial models
is modified adding another block what's
important to notice here is that uh even
if the first block although Frozen is
still delivered to the clients because
it is needed for the FED forward word uh
learning since there is no ongoing
optimization on this block it will not
require intensive computational
resources and uh the methodology out
outlined so far has been tested using
parallel training among multiple clients
in particular 10 uh using as aggregation
techniques both fed and fed procs we are
benchmarking our method so we are using
techniques well known in the field of
Federated learning and we also simulated
the effect of non of data through
distribution whose parameter beta
basically represent the level of
skewness in in in the data the smaller
Mark has to be done here uh usually in
real non scenarios uh typical values of
beta spans the the interval
0.51 in this case we also tested beta
0.3 at 0.1 in order to um to find out
how our algorithm perform also in some
sort of extreme
scenarios and these are basically the
results we obtained as beta varies we
can see compared also with the IID case
in this case we can see that uh
performances are good and consistent
unless beta becomes
0.1 where a drop in the accuracy can be
observed but it is somehow expected
since uh 0.1 is
means very different distributions of
data and so the risk of model model
model Divergence as I discussed it
before what's what is not reported here
but it is important is that these
results are in line with the
ones uh that can be found in literature
meaning that this idea ofl in the neural
networking blocks and then training the
blocks from different clients actually
works and reaches the same levels of
accuracy of other more standard
strategies we also conducted some
experiments involving uh the number of
the clients in particular we fix it beta
to uh 0.5 and we let the number of
clients vary between five and 50 and in
this case we can observe more or less
the same in the sense that uh for a
reasonable number of client from 5 to 20
the performances are quite good uh there
is a drop in the accuracies for uh 50
clients but since we are considering
beta equal 0.5 on 50 clients uh means
that uh few labels amount quantity will
be on on the local data sets over the
clients so also in this case is we are
we are fooling in a weakness of the
Federated learning process somehow and
finally we tested uh the behavior of
this approach as uh the number of blocks
assigned to which client is varied and
we compared these results uh with the
case of homogeneous Federated learning
in which all the clients train all the
blocks in this case we can see that uh
uh the per and in this measure these
tests are used as proxy for measuring
the behavior of the our approach in the
case for example uh all the clients have
are very uh have a very small uh
computational computational very SM
computational power and in this case we
can see that in the scenarios A and B uh
basically when some clients train a old
blocks or a an number of blocks the
performances are very good we can notice
a small drop in the in the performances
where all the clients only train a a
small number uh of of blocks but also
this is somehow expected since uh uh in
the in the procedure that trains blocks
then freeze the the first block add one
more block to the training process
probably some sort of information is
loose across this process and that's why
the performances are are a little worse
but in any case in line uh with with
what we say with what we saw before and
also with the case of homogeneous
Federated learning and this basically
concludes this uh this presentation just
a small remark about the two experiments
somehow the locally back propagated two
approaches proposed
the locally back propagated for forward
and Sh here uh of course uh there are
experimental setups we we we needed to
to understand if these approaches uh can
actually work and so we tested only in
the case of a classification task
involving two simple data sets amist and
passion amist only on feed for World
architectures of course now one uh
experiments will be exted Ed on
different architectures different tasks
involving more realistic data sets and
this is a brief list of the references I
used for for this talk and U that's it I
would like thank you for your attention
thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful talk of you um let's have a
Q&A sessions um if anyone has a
questions please unmute yourself and ask
questions
have you um applied this method to any
other data set no no uh as I said just
in the in the end of the
presentation uh the these were
preliminary investigations we wanted to
understand if this kind of hybrid
methodologies between the for forward
and back propagation can actually work
uh on an experimental setting so we we
taken out all the possible difficulties
coming from different data sets maybe
more realistic data sets or strange uh
neural architectures no uh now we know
that this kind of hybrid approaches can
be used of course they are not
uh uh usable on all the domains on all
the networks but they have
potentialities in my opinion and so we
will uh deepend investigations about
their possible usage and the limitations
they they have somehow yeah well
although you haven't applied that other
than amnest um amnest is like you know
basically 2D data right sorry I didn't
get your question we used the mnist and
fashion amist which is pretty similar to
amist uh so that's basically
two-dimensional data in data yeah
exactly they are in both the cases so
they are two dimensional data right we
didn't try with three-dimensional data
uh like CER 10 for example we didn't
actually we we conducted some
experiments for example on cifer uh but
uh we noticed that feed forward Network
struggle in reconstructing patterns of
cifer due to the high dimensionality of
the of the data so uh we we should
better investigate the suspect or uh try
uh the application of this kind of
learning strategies on conv other types
of of layers for example convolutional
networks in this case convolutional
layers in this case I see I see any like
expectations you have based on the
experience on this two dimensional okay
actually data yeah I I actually after we
worked on this uh in literature uh have
emerged some other manipulation of the
forward forward uh of the forward
forward algorithm which basically rely
on the on the approach uh uh we had that
is to say improve the collaboration of
the layers this is the probably the main
we weakness of this algorithm and this
is what it has to be pushed to uh uh
widen the range of the applicability of
this this algorithm uh all this to say a
thing that someone has tested this uh
this algorithm on
CNN uh by applying a twostep back
propagation alternate back propagation I
don't exactly remember the name of the
paper but it is a very interesting work
so I think
that these approaches can be extended to
at least two different
architectures okay thank you um is there
any other question from
audience if you do please unmute and
then ask
questions if not well let's thank our
speaker Fabio for the wonderful talk and
hopefully through this talk um there
will be some collaboration between uh
Fabio and some folks at the wom Le woman
National LA or um any other folks from
the outside thank you thank you thank
you very much and thank you again for uh
for this
opportunity have